here's what would happen if you wore 100  layers of makeup  well first off you'd be fighting an  endless breakout all those layers of  makeup would trap the dead skin cells of  the outer layer of your skin called the  stratum corneum  to cover up this bad breakout you'd be  tempted to put on even more makeup but  that would only make the problem worse  having makeup constantly on your face  could accelerate the aging process so  your skin would start breaking out and  becoming wrinkled  face would get drier each day due to  inflammation and it would begin to flake  to make matters worse your skin wouldn't  be able to absorb products correctly  acne and wrinkle fighting creams  wouldn't work luckily your skin can  recover if you treat it well you might  not be able to get rid of all your new  wrinkles completely but they become less  noticeable as your skin regenerates so